- Abordabilité, coût de la vie,
inflation : depuis le début
de la campagne, les chefs
cognent sur le même clou.
Et les électeurs en font aussi
une priorité.
YASMINE MEHDI
- C'est une préoccupation pour
beaucoup d'électeurs et
les partis politiques l'ont
compris. Chaque jour, on entend
des annonces et des promesses
pour aider les Ontariens à faire
face au coût de la viiii
explose. Mais est-ce que
cette réalité aura vraiment un
impact le jour du le 2 juin?
On est allé voir trois électeurs
avec des réalitéèèès
différentes pour sonder
leurs impressions à quelques
semaines du scrutin.
- Hey buddy, how was your day?
- Arrêt numéro 1, à Aurora,
en banlieue nord de Toronto.
Daniel Lajeunesse, 47 ans, a
denfnfnfants. Sa conjointe et
lui ont des emplois bien
rémunérés. Mais même pour eux,
les factures commencent à peser.
DANIEL LAJEUNESSE,
résident d'Aurora
- J'ai acheté une orange hier.
C'était 1.69$ pour une orange.
- Résultat : il faut couper dans
le budget familial et reporter
certaines dépenses.
- On aurait aimé peut-être
mettre une petite île...
- La rénovation de la cuisine
devra donc attendre quelques
mois.
En plus des effets immédiats
sur son portefeuille, Daniel
s'inquiète pour l'avenir
de sa famille, surtout avec
l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt.
- Est-ce qrererere retraite va
être repoussée? On ne pense même
plus à la retraite pour être
honnête. Même si ça devient
moins cher à la longue...
- Dastststst insatisfait
du gouvernement Ford, mais ne
révèle pas pour qui il votera.
- Je ne vote pas contre
un parti cette fois-ci, maisaia.
- Arrêt numéro 2 dans le centre-
ville de Toronto.
Sarah Abdillahi, 25 ans, ne sait
pas encore pour qui elle votera.
Mais l'inflation influencera
certainement sa décision.
"Tout coûte beaucoup plus
cher", remarque l'étudiante.
Pour faire face au coût de
la vie qui augmente, Sarah s'est
trouvé un emploi.
Mais à plus long-terme, elle
s'inquiète de ne pas avoir
les moyens de vivre à Toronto.
L'étudiante promet de voter,
mais se désole quepopopopopopols
de mesures spécifiques pour
aider les jeunes à faire face
à l'inflation.
Arrêt numéro 3 à
en banlieue éloignée de Toronto.
René Lessard, 67 ans, donnera
son appui à Doug Ford le 2 juin
prochain. Mais ce n'est pas
de gaieté de coeur qu'il votera
pour les conservateurs.
RENÉ LESSARD,
résident de Beeton
- Leteteteteteteurs, ils
dépensent trop. Ils dépensent
trop.
- Le policier à la retraite
a déjà dû faire des choixesesese
de l'inflation.
- Je l'aime bien, mais ça coûte
trop cher de le "runner".
- Comme celui d'arrêterutututute
qui roule au diesel.
Une situation irritante pour
lui, comme pour beaucoup
de ses voisins en milieu rural.
- Tout le monde qui demeure ici,
ils ont besoin de voitures,
Il n'y a pas de transport
public ici.
- Et ce n'est pas que derrière
le volant que René doit modifier
ses habitudes.
- Normalement, on mangerait plus
on en mange moins.
- En dépit de ces ajustements,
René se considère chanceux. r rz
d'épargnes pour faire face
à l'inflation.
- J'ai été gratteux toute ma vie
pas mal. Mais pour les jeunes,
moi, je trouve que c'est dur.
C'est à commencer.
- Poàààààààà l'inflation,
les conservateurs promettent
entre autres de réduire la taxe
sur l'essence. Les libéraux,
de fixer le prix du transport
1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1$. Et le NPD,
d'améliorer l'accès au logement
abordable. Autant de promesses
qui pourraient faire pencher
les indécis le 2 juin prochain.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Toronto